SPEAKER: If you've
been following along
with this series, you've got
a pretty good understanding
of the different techniques that
Cloud DLP uses to find, hide,
and protect sensitive data.
Today, we'll find
out how easy it
is to build and reuse
your commonly used DLP
configurations.
Stay tuned.
Kitty Cat Walks has already
been using DLP to inspect
and de-identify different
data sources like archive chat
log files, issues from their
ticketing system databases,
and data that they collect
from customers for billing.
Chances are, if you're
anything like Kitty Cat Walks,
the data you want to protect
may be from different sources.
And you may want to
inspect and de-identify
that data consistently using the
same configuration each time.
This is where DLP
templates come in.
Templates allow you to save
DLP configuration details
and reuse them against any
data that you might have,
essentially decoupling
configuration information
from the implementation
of your request.
There are two
types of templates.
An inspection template is
going to save any configuration
having to do with the process
of inspecting your data,
like what infotypes
you want to discover,
a likelihood threshold, maximum
number of findings to return,
and exclusion rules.
You can even use an
inspection template
to define your own
custom infotype.
Let's see what it looks
like to create a template
with some Node.js code.
Here's an example
of a request that
will send the
createInspectTemplate function
to create an inspection template
that's configured to find phone
numbers and email addresses
with a minimum likelihood
of possible.
Once it's been created, here's
what that template looks
like in our Cloud console.
There's the infotypes
we specified
and the likelihood too.
Let's edit our
inspection template
to also include person name.
We go here where it
says Manage Infotypes
and enter person name
in the search box.
Select it and click Done.
Now that we've saved our change,
our inspection template details
page specifies three infotypes.
Note this template path
at the top of the page.
We'll use that in a second.
To see our template in
action, let's check out
this inspection request.
Instead of constructing an
inspection configuration object
for this inspection
request, we can simply
reference the
inspection template
we created using the
path name like this.
Our response, of
course, would be
the results of the inspection.
As expected, we've got a phone
number, an email, and a name.
This is really useful if
you have several inspection
jobs set up against
different data sources that
inspect for the same infotypes.
Instead of editing each
inspection configuration
separately, you can simply
update the template details.
But hold up a second.
What about de-identification?
Well, the second
type of DLP template
is a de-identification template.
A de-identification
template is going
to save any configuration
having to do
with the process of
de-identifying your data.
For every positive result in
a de-identification request,
the template will have a
corresponding transformation
to apply to it.
This is also where
you would specify
transformation-specific
customizations like replacement
strings or encryption keys.
De-identification
templates can be
applied not only to
inspection results,
but also to values in a
specified field in a database
table.
Here's an example
of how we can use
the createDeidentifyTemplate
function
to create a new
de-identification template.
Here, we're specifying
that we want
to replace email addresses with
the corresponding infotype.
And we also want to make
sure that the names are
replaced with a custom
replacement value.
Once it's been created,
here's what the template looks
like back in our Cloud console.
Each infotype we specified
and its transformation
is listed here as a
transformation rule.
Just like our
inspect template, we
can edit it here to include
additional infotypes.
Let's edit this template to
apply masking to phone numbers.
Down here, we'll add
a transformation rule
and choose Mask with character.
Now we can configure our masking
for this transformation rule.
We'll specify the infotype
phone number down here
where it says Manage Infotypes.
Now that it's saved, there is
our new transformation rule.
De-identification templates
include a test page
where we can get a quick
preview of the transformations
we configured in the template.
Emails will be
replaced with infotype,
names are going to be replaced
with a replacement string,
and phone numbers will be
masked with hash symbols.
Now let's see our
de-identification template
do its thing in a
de-identification request.
Instead of including a
deidentifyConfig block
in a request, we can reference
our de-identification template
once again using the path
name from the Details page.
You'll notice that we're
referencing our inspection
template from before
to specify what
infotypes we're inspecting for.
And here is a response
from the request.
The inspection template
found a phone number, name,
and email address.
And a de-identification template
applied the transformations
we specified accordingly.
Using templates
is a powerful way
to decouple your inspection
and de-identification
configuration from
your workflows
and your implementation.
Inspection templates
can be configured
to inspect up to 150 built-in
and custom infotypes.
And de-identification
templates can
use any combination of
de-identification techniques
to de-identify the results.
We used a really simple example,
but the value of templates
really shines for
Kitty Cat Walks when
they got their data that
needs to be inspected
and de-identified coming from
their web and mobile apps,
archived on GCS
buckets, and stored
on a number of databases.
Reviewing templates
was a great way
to bring everything together.
Next time, we'll wrap things up
with an extended episode, where
we'll dive into configuring DLP
in the Google Cloud console.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]